Hello ya chas lovers and my friends this is
Gunjan here and today we are going to discuss about
a black opening cha has the
highest number of opening traps and the
opening we are going to discuss is the budha bus git now b bu git
starts like this  So
white p f black p knight s and after c4 e5 white take the
p and here black is to xenon
reply na to g4 and knight to
e4 what I have done in this lecture e first we are going to
deal with some of the nice
cute  Shot Traps Where White Does Not Play That
Much Sensibly and the Later Stages We're Going
to Discuss  is
knight c6 attacking on that e pawn  And if your
pawn is greedy and may be he wants to try to hang
on to that pawn by moving such as
f4 then black has a very nice move ch i
knight to b5 gaining a time on a queen well
if you have moved the queen outside  You Don't
Want to Put It Back Again on So Most Like
the Other Option for Those Who Want to Put on e4
Controlling the c2 Square Here Black is a Very Good Move
Small why trap i yo
pot i going to p e3 looks like defending upon defending the a
butt yer come the shuck
so bishop takes bishop takes and
after knight takes white can't take the knight because at the end it will be
[ __ ] by the  Knight
so that is a small cue trap ok in the f4
variation what about at this position white
plays sensible move like knight
f3 well here black continues
with the d6 and now there are two
lines first line uch is very
aggressive uch is this one bishop g5
g time no so b to bulk to bishop se now after
catcher
nice idea so blk capture not na
aking none and now
most logical snoot support a pn a
prathasan til unble but
to i her black can capture this pn and please
note  Any moves like a3 and the
moves played in the game for example
knightx can be met by a wonderful move I wonder if you spot it or its queen to check and
after the king takes knightx at
neither black nor the queen but if you look  At
the pawn structure isolated pawn and black re
comp structure and it will be very
useful asset in the mill game so one why tap in
queen f line ok another m ch i no Italy Bishop
G5 but f capturing pawn so crosses and now
black  Will play this bishop to e6 so gay time do
n't now please not
cross sen cross say don't help any cause
of white because the next move will be stopped till
a and black pc are coming out very
very fast so a why you don't  Want That
So Most Like The Pponent Is Going To Play This Mov
Queen Back To Base So Queen Backs To End Now
Black Capture This And Now If He
Played
A3 There Is A One Naughty
Trap If You Wish You Can Pause The Video And
You Can Try To  Find out it's really nice
one The shocking move knight to f2 and the seat
queen stays still so that is to take this knight Now comes the
beautiful move f2 and this
bishop is blocking the king dynal f2 going
back to support the queen and white  Simply lose
a queen over her sot i one of the naughty trumps if the pawn plays like a move like an ok sot
is some of the la son queen d f or
other moves for
example your pawn can play this move
queen d4 is  Somewhat similar to the queen
df line but this time white is attacking the
knight and defending the pawn black will judge the only one good
move is d6 so defending the
knight and attacking the pawn and after
captures black will capture this bishop
and  This position has so many threats and
first you can buy
the bishop check and gaining the white queen and the
first let's see some of the
options of the white so the first option is
white taking the pawn queen.  The game will be lusted after by
white because of these nice tactics The bishop does not give up
so now the queen is the only one to go and after this p
simply take the queen and
after bishop captures you can see the
beat square it has been taken and now  But simply a
rook up sot is a one cue trap a
white queen can go for the other pawn which is
now b7 pawn like this so queen goes to e4
and after the bishop p6 now I can take another pawn ch e
on b7 but after  The knight d7 you can
see already the black pieces are so much late
and white is only playing with the queen I
just like a beginner's opening and the black
is too pun down I would not prefer to be
white here as I have seen one game in  Data
Base Ch Goes Like This So
White Played e3 To Protect That Cf Pun Was
Attacked By The Bishop And Now
Black Simply Castle And Finally Won't Develop A
Peace We Have Knight Ath Buts Too Little Too Late Because
Black Has Nice Tactics Over Here
So  Black Plays Night See F And The Last
Horrible Mistake By White Was This One
Queen To Be F And I Wonder If You Can
Spot A Very Very Nice Tactics By Black
Okay So Black Plays Over Here Roop
To Be Now Queen Has Been Attacked And  You can see queen
is too sweet queen can go to see but if it
goes to c6 then rook to be and
queen doesn't belong to this world so in this
game white plaid queen a4 the only
square and now to is horror he has  To
face this
move and there are so many
threats over here ok let
me show you let's say if the bishop takes this knight then at least black can give a
check and
pick up this queen so that is not possible if
the queen king moves up for example  Like this then it will lose this
bishop
and the third possibility which actually
happens in the game is opponent plays like this queen goes
to d1 but after this move he
resigns because of this lovely folk so many
good threats available in this
line ok  There is another good trap available in
night f3 line in this line a its decent
looking move a black continues over here castle and
after there are also two possibility so one in
night
c3 logical move carrying no with falling now
black has this move night s  Gaining Time
The Queen Goes Back to Base and
Now Black Has This Moved Bishop to Cf So It's Coming Up Not
Juicy A2 S and Ld I Ring
The Trade of the Queen It's Not a Good Trade
for White So in This Game White
Defended first of late that but after
the queen
Not easy to defend because if the rook comes to the left then the
bishop f5 will be
naughty so it would be
almost a winning position for the
black
[music]
so let's say after this position instead of
knight
c3 If white is feeling not comfortable he can
play this
end  I can tell you this disaster m and we beat fuga with this move and the
move this knight goes to g3 and the move this knight goes to
g3  Lost the queen so in this game white played this move
queen e f but it's just
helping the black to develop the pc so
first black played this mm r gaining a time
au the queen so queen goes back to c2 and now again
gaining time au the  Queen So Attack
With The Night So Queen Finally Stable On The
Sea But Now
I Wonder If Y Can Spot The Nice
Tactics By The Black It's Very Very
Wonderful And The Move I This Move Na Nai Check Nai Tudi And
It's Very Amazing Move
And The  The problem is if the king comes to the D then it has to
face disc check
and it's very disaster position and if it comes to
especially comes to the lets to
finish here at the very end
so in this game what decided to capture
the night  And Meeting The Bishop
Chuck Please Note That Any Peace Come In Between Can Be Made By Simply Queen Takes Queen And That Cannot
Capture Buck Buzz E Pun Pin Pin So
White Is Powerfully To Go Here But To Her He
Relights It Has Been F By A Way So  This Way So
Now Its Family Fog And Las Position So Kind Of
Topas Can Be Like This Part Not
Filler With
Position Ok So T I About Queen D F And
Queen D F
Lie It's Much Threatening What Can Simply Give
Up The Pun  Sony Play Lock This
Just Give Buck The Material And Try To
Stabilize Position And First Time Not I See This I Can
Believe They Even The Traps
Available In This Line
And Just See This So Bishop Checks And If Knight With Then
Takes Bishop Takes Knight  And The Pun Will Be So
Very Obvious Response
Bishop To Det Now Comes Amazing
Not Any See Bulk Bulk Not Through Tech Been Buddy Theme
In Mass Kiss A Kiss Same Same Solely To Bulk
Chict Fes Ln A
Na Bulk
Simply Offer  Test Sample G But C The Kines
Isolated P And T Kind Of Positional
Advantage You Are Getting In Bp
Line Okay So Dos Are Sum Of The Shut Traps I Can Say
In The Night G F Line Now Let's See
Sum Of The Q Traps In  Knight e fla ch e
none s fja git if my profession e color please
excuse
me so na f and s i know of three the bishop
check and black going for the fast lap so in
the first le white knows about so he played
a3 stopping the  Bishop chucks and now black is this
m bush sorry s and after captures bishop takes
s and white place night a3 and true
nature looking can be a disaster if you are
not careful in budha paste and can you
spot it or its night take a  So again that
technique so king takes and bishop and the
queen does not belong to this wall so t e ky q ch
on akers in budha pest so please
watch out for two kind of traps and in
second
trap akers no white place this queen c2
so  Like playing the queen so Ali stages ca
n't be and bulk can exploit this so
first move I this m bishop chuck and here
in this game white played knight did some okay m it's
not bad and bulk place s and
after e cross
d bulk out with  Fast l so bishop idea in
na two and gaining time n the queen and
gaining the roo in the corner so white was
ready to go out from the witch so he gives check
so black plays knight c and now another bad move a
eight  If you are looking for it is
not a very good idea to play pas like
A3 and if it was so black play this move then I should
play queen too and accept
this position is not good but here
white becomes so much  Ambitious and he played this move pun takes
chch is look bit
natural because it's counter attacking the queen but I wonder if ya
can spot the nice
tactics by black ok the move played is
queen to e7 and now you can see that if the
queen goes back
TO
81 THEN THERE WILL BE NICE I MADE BY NIGHT SHAK
SO WHITE HAS ONLY ONE SWEER WHITE QUEEN
ONLY ONE SWEER WE HAVE TO GO OVER HERE BUT AS YOU CAN SUGGESTION A YOU CAN SEE SO MUCH EXPOSE
AND MOST LIKE GUN CASE SO BLACK EASILY
EXPLODE  This is so the first of the plaid at
six after the queen this moo bishop goes over here
and now the queen is check
mated and white plaid one last try but just bulk simply take it
and now the gun so that
is some of the nine steps available  In
Night e4 Line A So Far We Have Seen Were
Black Doesn't Sorry White Doesn't Play That Much
Accurately Now We're
Going to See Some of the Main Lines
of the Mercury Paste Well White Still Plays Very
Accurately But Still Fall Into Some of  The
our good traps so the first line we're going to see
is i knight g4 and bishop f4 so this
is one of the main line of the budap
bishop f4 hanging on to the sn with the
development so here
well I thought I should show show  You The Main
Budapest Trap Many Of You Know About It It's
Not Proper Video If I'm Not
Showing That Trap So Let Me First Show You That
Trap So That's A Famous Budapest
Trap That Inspires Many People To Play This
Git And It Goes  Like this so knight c6 knight c na
f3 defending no dan bishop checks i knight come then creep
so in this game white plays
knight black p queen se and after the moves
of a3 m like a3 bq m na f and i wat
takes bishop then v  Have nice mate so nice
bup and in let's say white know about tp a e
play moo sach ace knight
crow e5 knight cus c5 and now e3 then still you have a nice
game so your bishop
has to capture force move after n takes you
can  Places and even you can see if the
trap done work ya have still nice stable game
and there even three on this position so you can check it
out online ok so that is one of the
cute tree of Budapest
ok here sorry in this game  We Night See Sure
Play Bishop By Chuck And Okay White
Play Night But We Can
Understand This By We Night Son Couple So [ __ ] So
Night But And Now Comes Again This Ms And After
Grubbing This Pun Bulk Amazing Me Queen
A6 And An Yan  See only coming beat and
bush that by
day so late to defend this the first good way
logical way but then it can simply be done by taking the buck that takes
night ruck
in the corner
so to play this now and then after  Taking this pun
again white has the position kne l'arrad sots
e3 line and now at this
position in one of the game white played this in this
horrible looking
g3 and the trap works so effectively so
white plays this in sorry black plays this in  g5 and you can take it's a
very disaster
position for white so it can't move the bishop so wat tra this move but then again
black just
takes out the knight and that remains the same
and after the move s h3 sorry
a3 if black  Once he can gain a piece by taking the knight and then take the
bishop but the
black player was ambitious so he goes for this
line so he took this bishop and after
white recaptures this bishop he played this mf
cross g and please note if white  plaid f3 then will be
curtain for the white it's all
over so in the game wipe this very lucky knight f gaining
time no queen but after check
queen go over your check and fu moo of black
like this
black simply rack up in game
Game Continue Lock This Na And After
Queen Check He Fa Out Na Have Good I Have
Two Bucks Check A Then The Queen And It's Go To Be If Fire
For The Black So Many Good
Traps In Bishop A4 Line And Let Me
Discuss  A very very suspicious trap for ponent ch many people are
not aware and then after here at this
position white played a sensible and sad looking move ch is
night ok
idea i very simple so after night this
is wrong e3 it's not a i not  Don't want to be
ambitious just want to try to
concentrate on the development and am just
returning the pawn back ok fine no problem
so back will take here and normal moves
like bishop e2 try to castle on the king
side and here they are many moves but
One of the recent developments on this
line is gs which is functo in the bishop
on g7 and
here white played knight on c3 which is a
logical move and after bish sorry here black took
first that knight and then played the bishop.
to g7 OK there are books and videos
available on this line which tells you like this
so the three goes like this so queen
goes to d2 then b3 and bishop goes to g3 and then
g2 and castle on the king side and that is the whole third
Off this line but the problem with this theory is there is a
nice trap waiting to be
hit and I show you what I mean so in this
game with logical looking queen and
blk plays and after
b3 blk
play
and wide I know
Of He Might Play This My
Bishop Here Comes Tr So Queen Toes F At
First Glass I Look At This Poe I Thought Okay
It's Not A Big Deal There Are Many Ways To Defend This But More I Look At It More
I
Found It It's  Not at all easy for white to defend the for example if white
likes to castle o here then he has to
face this moo so he will be
exchanged down so that is not possible if white has to
play this moo f first side it looks like
to pc but then
after this move still
black is very
good so that is not possible and
finally we have this
one g3 f first side looks ok but that amazing move here wch
is queen to f6 so now the threat i
knight to a3 check and
Getting That Night On S3 And National Looking Too Like
Bishop To Beat Can Be Met Like This Might
A Thr Check Fo King And Queen
So T Has To Accept And Now Again Threatening The Rook And You Don't Believe But
White Can't Castle
Over Here  Because if it is castle then he has to face this move because only way to move like make the
checkmate is to move queen to d5 and then
atleast if white black wish he can capture the
rook after taking then
so in g is not possible and final choice  Play
in Game F F Cy Lu Ri Strange Chess
Bishop Top Piece But It's Nam B Na It and Yer Come
Amazing and OK
Black Can Play This Bishop to
A3 Now First See It Looks Unable But Many
Look at It M U F It's Very  Very
simple and now the thing is well
given many thing first of all easy
cross a3 then the worst
of the night so not
possible if ruk jeev then again na and now i catch then bulk catch ruk a now
the bishop p so again
disaster
So third option
i A4 f first side looks ok but after the
queen chuck still its disaster for white able to see
in minute so r
first
look it can be made by Nike a after that ave simply take
not a after touch dan yan
take  Bishop can't
play position White sot is not
possible but made
bass and now you can see it's a
disaster for white and
finally king can run away if king too but even do this
position is not good it's true that
blacks  Two pcs are hanging but see the
elegance of the position so first of the black
goes check so first piece comes out from the
danger so king goes over here and now the
second piece comes out and see
the white position it is artificial
castling kind of position of  The Wide Were the
Knight is Still Pin and Black Has a Pleasant
Position
Ch hee wa very
hot ath and hee pas na f and the
black play queen se and the good thing still the
white can't capture bishop buzz fok der na
a3
swer so white played
bishop beat and now black simply castle now
look at the side piece give  Are very hard to lop and
finally white p this in castling not the
queen side but
now it's actually threatening a bishop so we have to move a bishop bishop goes
back to f5 and now the simple plan is a54
and just a simply good
position so that  Was the Overall Package of the
Budha Pest Opening Traps A I Try to Cover as Many
Traps I Could Only Thing I Can
Remain in Your Own Game and You Never Know a May Any
Opponent Can Be a Victim and You Can
Use as a Shock Weapon  Even in the
tournaments well thank you for watching my
video
and please feel free to comment on my
video and I will meet you soon by